Transcriber: Josiane Chebl
المدقّق: Mohamed Salem
مرحباً
يا تُرى ماذا تعرفون عن الفقر؟
هل الفقر بالنسبة إليكم هو أن الإنسان
لا يستطيع تأمين طعامه وشرابه اليومي؟
أم الفقر بالنسبة إليكم
هو أن الإنسان يعيش في منطقة
فيها كوارث طبيعية أو حروب؟
أم أن الفقر بالنسبة إليكم هو أن يكون
راتب الإنسان أقل من 600 دولار سنويًا؟
ومع ذلك، منذ زمن كنا نقول
أن لا أحد ينام وهو جائع
ولكن الآن هناك الكثير من
الناس ينامون وهم جائعون
ليسوا جائعين للطعام والشراب فحسب
بل لأنبوبة الأوكسجين ولحبة فيتامينات
ولعلبة الدواء
هل أُصيب أحدكم بكورونا؟
أنا أُصبت به
الذي يخاف من العفريت، يخرج له
ظللت خائفة سنة ونصف من الكورونا
في كل مرة تخرج أختي من المنزل
أقول لها أنت من سيجلب لنا الكورنا
عندما كانت تقول لي إبنتي:
أريد أن أذهب عند أصدقائي
أو أريد الخروج للّعب
أو أريد الذهاب إلى المدرسة
كنت أقول لها ستصابين بالكورونا
لدرجة أن أطلقوا عليّ تسمية
شرطة الكورونا
أنا لم أنقل المرض لإبنتي فحسب
أنا نقلت لها الحاجة لخسارتي
لشغلي في بداية كورونا
هذه التجربة لم أكن الوحيدة التي مررت بها
هناك الكثير من الأشخاص خسروا
أعمالهم في بداية كورونا
ولم يستطيعوا تأمين الاحتياجات
الأساسية لعائلاتهم
زادت نسبة الفقر في العالم أجمعه
من ثمانين مليون لمئة وخمسين مليون
في سنة واحدة فقط بسبب الكورونا
أنا شفاء أم لطفلة
وناشطة بالعمل الإنساني
أصبح لدينا مصطلح جديد اسمه الفقر الصحي
هو الذي جعل الفقر من مجرد جوع
إلى تهديد بالموت
جميعنا كأشخاص كنا نحاول التعامل
مع التغيير الطارئ الذي حدث في حياتنا
ليس على المستويين الشخصي والمنزلي فحسب
لا بل على مستوى المجتمعات أيضًا
فقر صحي، فقر مادي، رعب
وخوف
هل هو هذا الجانب الوحيد للقصة؟
لا طبعًا. هناك جانب آخر جعلنا
ننظر إلى حياتنا بطريقة مختلفة
وكأنه أصبح هناك عدوى جديدة في حياتنا
اسمها كورونا
إنما عدوى إيجابية بين الناس
جميعنا كنا نحاول نساعد بعضنا
مثلًا الذي كان يملك بيتًا
كان ينتظر شهر واثنان وثلاثة على المستأجر
ولا يأخذ منه مبلغ الإيجار
أو يقلل الإيجار إلى النصف
كان دور الأطباء مهم جدًا في المستشفيات
ولكن أيضًا كان الأطباء يخرجون
ويتطوعون
ويساعدون الحالات المحتاجة في المنازل
ولا تستطيع الذهاب إلى المستشفى
ويقومون بنشر التوعية عن طريق
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
كانوا يقومون باستقبال
استشارات أونلاين أيضًا
متخيلين أن هناك شباب كانوا يأخذون إجازة
من عملهم ويخسرون أجرهم اليومي
فقط لتوزيع حصص غذائية لناس لا يعرفونهم
كانوا يخسرون أجرهم اليومي
من دون أن يعرفوا من أن سيؤمّنونه
لكنّهم يشعرون بالمسؤوليّة
الاجتماعيّة تجاه الآخرين
ولا ننسى دور السيدات الذي
كان عظيمًا جدًا في الأزمة
وخصوصًا السيدات التي كانت تعمل من البيت
السيدات التي عملت في البيت خاصة في الطبخ
كانت تحضّر وجبات صحيّة
وتعطيها للمحتاجين
مع أنهم بحاجة إلى كل جنيه يدخل منزلهم
ومع ذلك كانت تساعد غيرها
العيلة المصرية التي كانت
تصاب بالكورونا في الأزمة
كانوا جيرانهم السوريين يساعدونهم
ويجلبون احتياجاتهم ويدعمون
ويحسّسونهم أنهم ليسوا وحدهم
صحيح أننا لسنا من الجنسية ذاتها،
لكن نحن نساعد بعض
وهذا الكلام ليس فقط بين السوري والمصري
بين السوداني والعراقي واليمني
وكل الجنسيات الموجودة في مصر
هذه قصص ليست جديدة
بالنسبة إلينا
لو نعود إلى الماضي
في أوّل الأزمات العربية،
عندما هاجرت عائلات إلى مصر
كان المصريّون من أوّل
الداعمين إلى تلك العائلات
لا زلتُ أتذكر مصريّة كانت تجول في الشوارع
من الصباح إلى المساء
وتدقّ على منازل البوابين
وتسألهم: هل عندكم عائلة سورية؟
هل عندكم عائلة سودانية؟
هل عندكم عائلة يمنيّة؟
وتزورهم وتطمئنهم
وتدعمهم وتحاول مساعدتهم
ماديًا ونفسيًا
ولو احتاجوا إلى
العمل أمّنت لهم
وتبقى إلى جانبهم
إلى أن يتجاوزوا هذه الأزمة
دائمًا كنت أقول أن البقاء على
هذه الأرض ليس للأقوى أبدًا
البقاء هو للذين يقدرون أن
يديروا أزماتهم سويًّا بشكل صحيح
شكرًا